foreign
let's go to Devin in Post Falls what's
up Devin
how's it going partying man
what are you up to
uh just standing outside uh excited for
this phone call uh is it cold
yes dude go inside man I'm not worth it
pneumonia
oh no it's fine it's nice to keep the
fresh air
um I was actually in Nashville Tennessee
this last week and the weather there is
much nicer
I mean so what's up brother how can I
help
so I've made over the last
I don't know 10 months 12 months I've
made a lot of changes in my life uh I
switched jobs uh changed the people who
I hang around with uh quit drinking and
then I think the biggest thing is I lost
I'm at about 115 pounds now what
you've lost 115 pounds in 10 months
yeah homie dude that's incredible man
way to go
uh actually that did have a lot to do
with it yeah it did and I'm fine it
didn't look
uh your your book on your past change
your future uh when I decided that I
needed to do something different because
I'm 32 now and I was kind of out of
stalemate I can't just do the same thing
my whole life and my brother recommended
it so okay didn't really think much of
it and listened to it picked up a little
bit and a little bit more
um so I think that that helped me
realize that there were things inside of
me that I needed to work on not just oh
you need to lose weight like there's a
reason why I was like that
it's awesome dude I'm so I can't I'm so
proud of you dude it's amazing it's
incredible thank you it's incredible
dude
I feel much better and healthier now I
bet you can stand outside and it's zero
degrees and talk on the phone that's
amazing man I'm so bad I'm so proud of
you it's awesome
um thank you and uh unless don't blow by
this like losing weights really hard
it's one of the biggest challenges
stopping drinking is really hard I
actually think underneath what you've
done the hardest thing you've done is
you've changed your Social Circles
that's real hard man making friends when
you're 30 is the worst it's the worst
right that's hard you've done a lot of
hard stuff man I'm so proud of you dude
that's amazing
thank you
um and now I feel like I'm I'm at this
point where I want to change some more
things I want to I guess I'm looking at
my future more than I ever used to
because it
just like I see things for myself like I
need to be a better person and whatever
and now like with the weight loss it was
it was easy to set goals and meet these
markers and
now I'm kind of
I feel like I'm overthinking everything
I'll look at a different career I'm like
oh I can maybe do that but there's these
downsides and
it sorry sorry I'm rambling a little no
you're not rambling to
feel like I'm confidently making those
decisions versus is this just going to
be another
decision I make that doesn't ultimately
help me to get to where I want to be
okay so yeah man
what you are asking is such an important
question that I think quite frankly our
culture misses dramatically okay I'm so
grateful that you called a so we could
celebrate your successes it's amazing
but two
um
you've entered into this really
important world where we don't have a
psychology for this in our culture and
here's what it is I think
um where you want to go your quote
unquote goals those are important but
they're often the wrong question
here's what I mean by that
um the number of times I go work with
Business Leaders all across the country
and we get behind closed doors and we
have some hard conversations about their
numbers and their books and their
personnel all that kind of stuff
and I'm just going to make up numbers
here but let's say it's real easy to get
have a strategic planning
um opportunity sit down look at your
numbers dream big come up with the b-hag
they call it the big hairy audacious
goal and
to say we're going to be a 500 million
dollar company that's our goal that's
what we're gonna go do come like we're
crushing it we're killing it that's our
goal
what you've accidentally done is you
have set a metric
that does not take into account covid or
inflation or hey we don't have any glass
because of uh supply chain issues
and so instead of doing the hard work
which is saying here's who we're gonna
be
on the way to wherever it is we're going
that's way harder to do and to see
through
because then what happens is you have
employees that the world shifts
underneath you but you still got that
500 that 500 million dollar Benchmark
out there so they start cutting Corners
they start making a little bit of a
worse loan than they would otherwise and
they don't tell anybody about it or they
somehow get it through committee hey
I'll say yes to this loan if you'll say
yes to my loan and let's go ahead and
bundle and sell these loans and now
you've you've got people doing whatever
it takes to hit that quote unquote goal
and you've you've had a goal my guess is
I'm gonna lose 100 pounds or whatever
if you're not careful you start starving
yourself
or you start taking a bunch of not good
medicine from the doctors some really
extraordinary medicine out there now um
for weight loss but you start just
taking a bunch of amphetamines and you
see what I'm saying like you'll cut
Corners to get there
and you start cheating away in days and
all of a sudden you get your number
but you don't like who you are when you
get there or you get your number and
everything around using Ash you see what
I'm saying so you've made so what you've
proven to yourself is that in one year
Devin can do freaking anything
anything okay you've tackled the three
big heart the hardest things I know of
alcohol weight loss and friend circles
you get it all
so in terms of like who do I want on my
on my team
who do I want to go into battle with
your first right because if I if if if
you say I'll get to the other side of
that line I 100 know you're gonna get
there okay so
you're always going to have
opportunities for jobs because there's
not a job on Earth that doesn't want a
guy like you on that team
what you've got to stop doing but you
you can't seek that approval
what you have to do is just ask yourself
the hard question is
who do I want to be to wherever wherever
it is I'm going
and this goes back to Identity
I'm a guy who takes care of his body
and at some point my body's gonna stop
losing weight I am going to have to I'm
gonna start lifting I'm gonna try this
out I might start running some
regardless of what those little mini
goals are I'm gonna run a half marathon
one day or I'm gonna walk uh whatever
I'm gonna I want to bench press this
much weight all those goals are fine
but they're in service to I'm a guy
who's a good Steward of his body
and occasionally like I that's one of my
identities like I'm a guy who takes care
of his his body so that I can be a good
dad so I can be a good employee so that
I can work really hard and show up
and the last like a couple of months I
think I've talked about the show I was
finishing up a book and I had to check
myself into a hotel a few times and just
write 24 7 and finish this thing
in that season I did not was not a good
Steward of my body my body worked really
hard I redlined it and so now I'm
putting money back in the bank right I'm
trying to take care of myself I'm in a
season so it goes and Seasons it's not
good but it's all in service to this
identity so let me ask you
you've proven to yourself I could do
anything
who do you want to be now what kind of
Life do you want to have do you want to
have a funny life an adventurous life a
life that you are just going to spend
the next five years grinding it out
working really hard making a bunch of
money like what what do you what do you
want what do you want to feel like
I
I just
hmm
you know that's a good question
I
I like to help people I kind of looked
towards like first responder type thing
because I
I feel like there was times in my life
where I
maybe could have used some help or maybe
there was people that were there to help
and I didn't reach out but I don't it
just
I like to do things like that
um
I don't know so let me tell you this so
um one of my identities that I've I've
taken on
and I got this from a mentor
is I want people to be a little more
peaceful after they get done interacting
with me than before
and what that frees me up is if I choose
to go be a first responder and just quit
this job
that still applies
if I go back to working at Burger King
where I worked when I was in high school
My Hope Is I can have inject a little
bit of humanity into that exchange when
they're buying their Whopper with cheese
or whatever
and I hope that that person's a little
more peaceful a little more joyful a
little more Smiley after they interact
with me than before
and so you like to help people
I want you to go one step deeper and
begin to ask yourself
how do I want people to experience me
and I want you to keep this this just
tattoo this on your heart from this
point forward because you've proven all
you need to prove
I want you to tattoo this on your soul
it's about identity not destination
because you're going to end up where if
you wherever you end up you can't do
anything about the world economy
imploding or like chat GPT becoming the
next internet and we all make even more
money than we've made the last 25 years
right you can't or gas prices going up
to 500 a gallon you can't you can't do
anything about those things zero
and so the important energy I want you
to spend is who do I want to be wherever
it is I'm going
I want to be a guy this is this is Devin
this is me telling you I want to be a
guy that has a reputation for working
really hard and always getting the job
done no matter what
I want that okay so that means I gotta
take care of my body that means I gotta
get enough sleep that means I gotta have
friends and community in my in my in my
corner that also means and I struggle
with this I gotta be on time
I have to always meet my deadlines right
so all I have to say is that's one of my
so I want you to get four or five or six
identities here's who I'm gonna be
Here's Where I Wanna Be in this next
phase and the beauty of what you have is
most people start those identities at
the beginning of this 10-month journey
you did it without it you just said I'm
I'm going all in so now you can create
these you can lay out these identities
and begin to backfill the action steps
you need to take
with no reservation you've got no
Governor because you can do it freaking
anything Devin
that does make sense I
okay
uh I was just hoping for like you should
go working in banking right
that that has been a consideration I did
some CPA classes and stuff when I was in
high school got some college credits
like I tend to do well in that kind of
stuff I just Devin I'm telling you I'm
telling you right now I've hired more
people than I can count I can't tell you
how many people I've hired over my
career
I can also can't tell you how many
people I've consulted how many
businesses all from plumbers to colleges
to all everybody in between
you will never long for a job
because they don't make people like you
there's very few of you out there
and I'm convinced that you could get put
as a technical writer and you hate
writing and you don't like grammar and
you would do well you'd figure it out it
might take a little bit of your soul I'm
really really good at Big budgets at
dealing with budgets
and it takes a little bit of my soul
every time I do it right every time I
hit submit I I it part of me dies a
little bit but I can do it real well
you can do whatever you want to
I'm gonna send you my buddy Ken Coleman
has a get clear assessment that kind of
narrows it down it helps you start to
link this identity with what are some
things that I would be really good at
I'm going to send it to you for free and
I want you to utilize that I'm also
going to send you his book from paycheck
to purpose and that is a like okay I got
all these skills
where can I go and purpose is really I I
love how my friend Jade Simmons says it
purpose is how I other people experience
me
purpose is what I Inspire in other
people
and this is going to keep you from going
I just need another job any other job
any other career too
what were you put on this Earth to do
man
and I actually don't think that's one
thing I think that's a way of being I
think that's an identity but that's just
me
um what was I put her to do how am I
gonna go make that happen who am I gonna
be on this journey
and dude it's it can be paralyzing
because now the the whole field is open
you can kind of run where you want to
run and you've proven to everybody
you're real real fast
question you got to ask yourself is who
am I going to be wherever it is I'm
going
and dude I cannot wait to see where you
end up the world needs more people like
you my brother and it's an honor I've
gotten to spend some time with you